hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
problems when it comes to friendships
that inevitably arises for many of us
and which Cicero devotes some discussion
to in his work on friendship is
unfortunately that quite a few
friendships will end and it's
interesting that he provides advice
drawn from other people including Cato
the great stoic philosopher and
statesman and from his own experience
about how best to extricate oneself from
from friendships that have you might say
gone sour something is is wrong with the
relationships and so we're best off by
considering well why is it that
friendships end and there's there's a
number of different possibilities one
would be the vice of the person who is
not the one ending the friendship but
the one who has to end it he says that
there are often in friends outbursts of
vice which affect sometimes their actual
friends sometimes strangers yet so that
the infamy of the evil flows over onto
the friends now that's some pretty old
fashioned language but I think we can
bring this into the present
imagine that you're out at a you know
restaurant having some appetizers and
then a meal and drinks with one of your
friend and they've had a bad day
something went wrong at their workplace
and something's going wrong maybe when
their their love life their stock
portfolio took a hit who knows what it
is right whatever it is that it's
weighing on their mind and they are
really crappy to the service staff and
they get into an argument with say the
waiter and the manager has to come over
and then they're fighting with the
manager and it gets the level of
shouting profanity and swinging at them
and getting thrown out of the restaurant
now you know you're sitting there like
well what is going on here you know this
is this is my friend
should I be backing them up they're
acting like a real jerk to other people
I don't think I should be condoning this
behavior now let's say that this friend
you know in addition to doing that they
get thrown out of the restaurant and
they're like are you coming and you're
like yeah I guess meals over now and you
go out and they're like can you believe
that nonsense and you're like man you
need to calm down you know I think you
were actually in the wrong here and then
they turn on you and they're now they're
blowing up at you you're like all right
I'm out of here and you get in your car
and you drive away and you're like that
was a really unpleasant experience and
then you know you're not even home
before they're texting you about how you
know you're such a bad friend and you
should have taken their side now there's
a couple different vices going on there
the person didn't manage their anger
well they you know may have problems
with you know generosity or kindness
with others there could be all sorts of
other issues involved there that might
be the sort of thing you're like I don't
know what I want to be friends with this
person anymore
and we could come up with plenty of
other examples as well you find out that
your friend is into some sort of
practice that you simply can't condone
and you're like yeah you know I thought
I was cool with this but I think you're
kind of disgusting and I'm not going to
deal with this anymore or they're doing
something that's that's unjust
you know so there there's an issue there
and then another one that that sister
was talked about at quite quite you know
length is is what do you do when friends
make demands on you based on your
friendship based on loyalty that you do
the wrong thing whether by action or
omission that you in some way cooperate
in badness those are things that break
up friendships you know prime example of
that is your friend cheats on their
significant other tells you who is
friends with their significant other and
you know this isn't the first time that
they've cheated that they need to keep
you need to keep this secret so that it
there aren't any negative consequences
for for them and it doesn't hurt the
significant others feelings and it you
know keeps the relationship going this
is a genuine dilemma and it's not a good
thing for a friend to ask right but that
can destroy friendships as well then
there can be differences that arise and
Cicero brings up some prime examples of
this he says that we might have a change
in dis disposition he says out moorim
out studio Durham Cuomo taught co-write
as a nice phrase change of disposition
and and tastes more room is mores that
means your your habits the ways in which
you behave so disposition translates
that's quite quite well studio time the
things that you devote yourself to you
know you may have become friends with
somebody because you're into the
ill-fated series Game of Thrones if you
don't know what that is it's a HBO
series that I believe ran for eight
seasons and was based at the start very
closely and by the end very loosely
George RR Martin's Song of Ice and Fire
let's say that you're you were into the
Song of Ice and Fire books which are
quite good and then you got into the
series and if you know you became
friends with somebody because you would
talk back and forth about what was going
on in the show and you would start you
had a ritual he'd show up to each
other's place every week to watch the
new episode in
in as the seasons ran on right you bring
the beer this time and I'll have the
popcorn or whatever it's gonna be and
you you developed a kind of intimacy now
let's say here that we'll make it an
even more interesting example let's say
that your friend is a trend Bucer right
because pretty much everybody's agreed
that the last season and in particular
the ending of Game of Thrones on HBO was
garbage from from a narrative
perspective it was just awful that's why
there's there you know people engaging
in it anymore it's it's lost its it's
sort of luster that it had but your
friend is a contrary in' your friend
says i think it was one of the best
seasons ever and this is wonderful and
you're like come on man look at the
books look look at how good the writing
was at the start when it was drawing
heavily on george RR martin and look at
all these different characters that they
did basically just threw away with
stupid hollywood tropes and you know
they just made a complete mess of it
it's not even coherent by the end right
and now you you disagree this is a
disagreement in what Cicero is calling
your studio right you're your tastes so
you know that can provoke an end to the
friendship as well
he also quite you know importantly for
our own times attracts about a
difference in political views things
about the in very public I party bus
right the things that concern we might
say not just politics but society and
culture people drift apart when it comes
to those matters so how how should we
handle this
Cicero tells us we need to be very very
careful in in and you know breaking off
our friendships why well he's on to
something really important here when we
have a hasty break it often turns into a
nasty break right it produces hostility
it produces hatred there's nobody who's
quite so capable of hating as somebody
who originally loved you know we've all
heard the thing about a person spur
well that applies even more to
friendships and so this is a real risk
and he gives some some interesting
examples here of things that happen like
that it's very common that when there's
an intimate relationship with people
when they've shared a lot when they know
we're each other's vulnerabilities are
when they have a sense of expectations
from each other if the if the friendship
is broken off right away that at least
one of the people in it will become
quite aggressive with the other one and
this could be physically slashing tires
stalking them this could be on the
internet you know writing terrible
things about them and then that you have
to block them or something like that
they're there there's an entire range of
bad behaviors that people engage in and
Cicero says you don't want to arouse
resentment particularly if you're the
one breaking off the relationship so he
gives Cato's advice and Cato suggests
that when these sorts of things happen
we should have a gradual relaxation of
intimacy and this is a translation of a
misión a uses the lusus is can be
translated as use but it can also be
translated as sort of what we do
together the custom that we have again
if we're using the Game of Thrones thing
maybe you stopped showing up at the
person's place or you spend less time
you don't hang around chitchat with them
and the sessions get you know further
and further apart and shorter and
shorter and you're you know you're not
ghosting them but you're not responding
to texts right away about about things
so a gradual relaxation of intimacy
rather than simply breaking it off right
away right and in some cases is left the
person get the hint and they're like oh
yeah I guess we're not that close
or since friendship you know often does
depend on how often we're connected with
each other that can can lower it may be
the person gets really busy and you
don't have to worry about it and he also
suggested an unraveling rather than
breaking the friendship this Tsuen die
is is that that's a gerund abused of the
friendships they
to be unraveled rather than breaking
them discs end end day right and we
might use the word disentangle and think
of it as like a friendship being like a
knot you you don't want to just cut the
knot you know the story the famous
Gordian knot right Alexander the Great
comes across this this famous knot that
can't be unraveled he takes his sword he
just cuts it and he's like problem
solved well that's not problem solved
when it comes to delicate human
relationships and where each of these
threads is a tie of affection or a
memory or something along those lines so
instead he got a can't pull of things
and slowly unravel them the unraveling
would be would be sort of like you know
a woven piece of fabric right he does
make an exception he says that there
could be some things that a person is
doing where you really do have to break
off the friendship right away as we say
pull the band-aid off you know the
contemporary expression band-aids hurt
when you pull them off usually because
they're connected to your hair right and
they pull the hair out and is it better
to like slowly peel it back or is it
better just to rip it off right away
well in some cases it's better to do
that what would be the criteria for that
it's not you know that you your
psychological comfort or something like
that it's that the person is doing
something genuinely wrong and you cannot
cooperate in this anymore so that that
would be you know he called Cicero talks
about some unendurable wrongdoing
something where you're like this this
went too far man I can't I can't deal
with you anymore
now Cicero gives a few additions to
Cato's advice that also seem good and
one he says that there should be care
that no discord arises so you don't want
to just like walk in and say hey done
with you see you later
have a good life good luck you want to
make sure that you're not having any
disagreements or discord arising because
you know that the person is probably not
going to be happy about the friendship
and
he also now this may sound since he uses
the word appearance video net in in
Latin it may seem a little bit sketchy
to some of you he says you want there to
be an appearance that the friendship has
burned out rather than been stamped out
and the metaphor here of course is of a
fire so you know if you don't if you
just don't feed a fire eventually it
turns into embers and then those embers
die out right there's other ways of
putting out a fire very quickly and one
of them is stamping on it and that is a
more active thing instead of just not
feeding the fire tending the fire you're
putting the fire to death you could say
and so he says you want to avoid doing
that you want to avoid the appearance of
that and then he also tells us one other
thing that's quite interesting here he
suggests that if hatred does result if
your former friend is angry with you
becomes an enemy starts bad-mouthing you
trying to create conflict stir up drama
then he says just bear with it don't
don't get involved in the back-and-forth
of that that's not going to be a good
idea and he suggests the way that we can
do this he says we can pay respect we
can keep in mind the old friendship the
former friendship that we had and we can
remind ourselves this person used to be
a friend and we can might go beyond this
as well and if we understand this
dynamic we might say well it's it's it's
understandable that they're gonna be
angry with me and upset and say these
sorts of things because people don't
like having their relationships broken
off but I do need to break it off so I'm
just gonna put up with this and keep my
head down and and not respond in kind so
this is Cicero's advice about how we
extricate ourselves from the friendships
that no longer are good friendships and
may in fact place us at risk if we don't
get out of them eventually of some big
blow up and a break off that produces
hatred enmity
resentment which we want to try to avoid
not just for ourself but also for the
former friend because that's a good
thing on both sides
you